i lived here in greenwood mississippi
off and on from the age of seven
until i was 18.
i crossed a lot of hurdles here
started first grade learned how to drive
a car
fell in love with the first time i also
crossed another hurdle here
i experienced death
my paternal grandmother my brother
and we all go through this of course
everybody grieves
but some people have a certainty that
helps them cope with me
they are certain they will see their
loved ones again in heaven
the samples is not quite that simple in
fact
it's the greatest question we ask
ourselves
what happens when we die
now i'm embarking on an epic adventure
to discover what we believe lies beyond
death and why
is there any scientific support from the
soul
i learn the true purpose of the
afterlife for ancient egyptians
oh my goodness look at all this why the
story of one man's rebirth was so
powerful
it swept the globe it is the
resurrection of jesus
that proves that he's the messiah how
the hindu faith erased the fear of death
i accept that as an inevitable part of
life
and i'll explore how science is trying
to capture the soul
i hope to be full and human someday
to bring eternal life to this life
what is beyond death how can any of us
know but
some people think they do because
they've been to the brink of death
[Music]
former research diver david bennett is
one of those people
which one are you looking at this window
here
one with jesus in the lower corner there
he's quieting the storm
back in 1983 off the california coast
there was a storm
25 to 30 foot seas and so we started
heading in
and all of a sudden we fell off a
30-footer that fast
and we just slid right off
it looked up and there was the next one
and it came right down on top of us
i was in the bow it catapulted me into
the sea
and i was just tumbled and tossed like a
rag doll
you can only hold your breath so long
[Music]
you reach a point of release where you
just you just let go
and you breathe in salt water and
it's it's quite a violent way to die
no idea how deep i had i totally lost
my awareness of my body in the ocean at
this point
then i noticed this light
it was millions upon millions of
fragments of light
in all different colors and they were
all dancing and swirling
kind of like they were one mind though
and it was infinite
what did you think did you think of just
experiencing this feeling
well i mean i knew i wasn't in kansas
anymore you know
i knew i had left my body
and as i approached this mass of light
it was a familiar home and
and it was a relationship just so much
deeper than any relationship i'd ever
had here
and then i reached a certain point where
these millions of fragments of light
spoke
and they said this is not your time
you must return you have a purpose
i was watching my body and i was
mesmerized
because i knew i was going to go back in
that body
and as the next set of waves came they
pounded my body up against all this
wreckage and pushed some of that salt
water out of my lungs
and that's when i found myself back in
my body
about how long were you in
the water on yeah the the crew that were
looking for me said i was there from
anywhere from 15 to 18 minutes under
just
under the water 15 to 18 minutes yeah
so you're 15 8 to 18 minutes without a
breath of air
right okay
so david all that you've told me is
it's such a story
does it make you believe in an afterlife
i do believe in an afterlife i believe
that
our being our soul whatever you may want
to call it
lives on and that
we have opportunities to come back and i
never
thought of any of that beforehand i i'm
it just wasn't on my radar
now here we sit in this cathedral
you haven't mentioned god that light
that was god to me that was god
so the message is from god
yeah and i believe that you can find
that spirituality
in all different beliefs i don't
subscribe to just one belief anymore i
try i love
my library at home has all different
beliefs represented
so does mine
david's incredible story reminds me of
an experience i had many years ago
i have seen a light not in a near-death
experience i was just passing out
and what i perceived was
the tiniest beam of light
that to me was the
final form of life
it just occurred to me holy cow there it
is there is the light that everybody
talks about
but it's a common theme among people who
say they have had a near-death
experience before
or an out-of-body experience what they
see is a light
some people have seen jesus in in this
light
other people just see a bright light
the hope for life beyond death seems to
be an almost universal instinct
but i want to know how the afterlife
first became part of religion
so i'm going to egypt
to the place where the first great
monuments to the afterlife
still stand
here we are at sakara that's a step
pyramid of king zosa
and it's one of the first pyramids it is
the first pyramid ever to be built
that one is over there yep this entire
site
is a big cemetery so the ideas that
people now have
about rebirth and resurrection all
started here in sakara
about 5 000 years ago if not earlier so
this is maybe the birth of afterlife
thought
yeah you could say that
egyptologist salima ikram is taking me
to see the tune
of a pharaoh who ruled almost 400 years
ago
inside it are humanity's oldest written
descriptions
of the afterlife
and this is a causeway and we're going
towards the temple
of unas this part is where they would be
dragging
the body of the king once it had been
mummified up here
i'm looking here at these stones i know
i couldn't lift one
and it looks like it was built in the
50s or 60s
but it was actually built in about 4 000
years ago
bit more than that unbelievable still
unbelievable
if we go up here you can see there's the
pyramid
and it doesn't look like very much right
now it looks really like
a hill yep but what's important about it
is what's inside
you're going to have to mind your head
was this little people in here nice eyes
so you'll have to duck again for this
[ __ ]
it's also you have to bend to show that
you're being
respectful to the great god king is that
what this is all about
partially yeah and
here we are
and this oh my goodness look at all this
fabulous man
what is all the writing about basically
these are magic spells or religious
spells
that unass had inscribed so that when he
wanted to go from this world to the next
he had to recite all of these things and
they give him directions
if he's going to pass through anything
dangerous
what to do what to say
what do these prayers say well there's
one
here that you know rise up on us and
we'll know the magic and you can be
triumphant over the demons
over here unasked will go forward and
his soul will live forever so basically
this one gives him dominance over any
demon-faced creatures and you see his
name repeated again and again and again
throughout the war okay that's what i
was looking at there's so much
repetition but that's his name
these sacred spells are a survival guide
for souls passing through the underworld
and the key to understanding why the
afterlife was so important to the
egyptians
okay this is the main burial chamber
this is it this is the main event
and this is the oh my goodness this is a
sarcophagus yep this is this big
fat thing is the sarcophagus and that's
when oonage would have been
laid well i'm sorry he's not here i'd
like to shake his hand say hello
how you been what's going on
okay and are these more spells
yep and so this whole thing is really
this resurrection machine for unass
and his spirit
at nightfall unes soul would reanimate
his mummified body and make a
treacherous journey
he would cross a lake of fire passing
through gates guarded by demons
and snakes without his sacred spells
he would be devoured with them
he could arrive and sit with the eternal
gods in the starry heavens
he wakes up at night he gets up and he
starts his
his journeys the next night he wakes up
and he starts and he does the exact same
thing all over again and then the next
night
he gets up and he does the same thing
all over and then the next night
he gets up and he turns in it it's a bit
tiring
maybe maybe not i mean harley's a god
yeah i guess so
all right you know that's that's what a
king does because
by doing this by going through this
eternal battle and being becoming one
with
sun god what the king does is make the
world
safe okay do we have to um
is there another way out up here do we
have to bend over again
sorry we have to bend over again to
become one with the eternal stars
read on for the ancient egyptians
the afterlife of the pharaoh was vital
it ensured the sun would rise each
morning
very enormous monuments didn't just
ensure the pharaohs would survive beyond
death
their afterlife provided essential power
to sustain the living
this idea is not unique to egypt halfway
around the world
a culture that never had any contact
with the ancient near east
also came to depend on the power of the
dead
this is mexico city on the day
of the dead
archaeologist enrique rodriguez alegria
has been studying how mexicans and their
mesoamerican ancestors
see the afterlife this is the one night
of the year where people can spend
the entire night with the souls of
their ancestors and the souls can come
and visit
and they can share food and then they
can share
jokes and stories and enjoy a night
together
the gonzalez family greet that dead
grandfather with a traditional song
imploring him to wake up
the belief that the division between
life and death
is not very firm and it's definitely not
as firm as it is for example in the
united states
the day of the dead developed from the
catholic faiths all souls and all saints
days
but the heart of the celebration is much
older
it dates back to the aztec ideas of the
afterlife
a tradition that is profoundly
unchristian
at the center of modern mexico city only
the ruins of the aztec
temple mayor still remain
five hundred years ago a colossal
pyramid temple dominated the skyline of
tenochtitlan
when the conquistadors first arrived
they described scenes of mass sacrifice
by aztec priests
who pulled beating hearts out of living
victims
bodies and blood cascaded down temple
steps
but that will scan physical evidence of
these mass sacrifices
until a recent chilling archaeological
discovery
in the basement of an old house so the
temple major is
right there right
we are only about 600 feet
away from the temple major wow
here enrique's colleague raul barrera
unearthed remains of a rack of human
skulls over
a hundred feet long bueno a temporary
so this is a wall made of skulls
joined by lime and it is associated or
it is part
of the skull rack the great sao panthe
of the essex it's incredible it's been
right here
for 500 years brutal as it seems to us
now
the aztecs saw human sacrifice as vital
without human blood they believed the
sun would lose power
crops would fail without the power drawn
from the death of a few
all life would come to an end what the
essex believed
was that if they stopped doing
sacrifices it would be
the end of the world the gods would be
displeased
the sun would stop moving and it would
not make its journey
across the sky during the day a
sacrifice connected
the living and the dead because people
who who died in sacrifice providing for
the people who remained here
and they continued making this worldly
life
possible for those who remain behind
the human sacrifice of the aztecs and
the elaborate tombs of ancient egypt
are both driven by a common belief in
the afterlife
the dead have the power to reach back
and sustain the living
but today billions of people believe
this power can do
more than sustain us in this world
it can grant us all eternal life
most of my family are buried near my
home
gives me a sense of rootedness that i
need
give me occasion to remember reflect
on how their lives influenced me
this in itself is a form of life after
death
our memories of them continue to guide
us
when their life on earth
has ended for christians
a graveyard is not just a place of
memory it's a place of hope
for life beyond death hope that began in
a moment of extreme anguish
2000 years ago
when a man named jesus was arrested by
the romans
in jerusalem and sent to die on the
cross
[Music]
it's a story most of us in the west know
or think we know
but i want to examine this promise of an
afterlife more deeply
so i've come to the place where the
story began
jerusalem
to try to understand what it meant to
people living here some
two millennia ago today
this city is home to three faiths
judaism
christianity and islam
back then almost all the locals were
jewish
including jesus is that the top dome the
dome of it right there
the great thing that you see right
that's the main dome and then the
dome over the tomb which has its own
grey dome is located on the other side
of that to the west
okay i've asked archaeologist jody
magnus
to show me where many christians believe
jesus died
so this is it this is the church of the
holy sepulchre
this is the church of the holy sepulchre
this is an enormous
complex that enshrines the sites
that are holiest to christians holiest
in the world
in the time of jesus this area lay
outside the walls of the city of
jerusalem
the site where he was crucified was a
rocky hill
that's called golgotha which means the
hill of the skull
because this was a spot where the romans
crucified people and there were skulls
and bones lying around
christians have made pilgrimage to the
church of the holy sepulchre for more
than 1600 years
not only is it revered as the site of
jesus's crucifixion
it also contains another holy shrine
what is believed to be the remains of
the tomb where jesus was buried
and rose from the dead
you can really feel the energy here
this spot is the focus of so much
devotion
the tomb no longer looks anything like a
first century jewish burial place
but jody believes this site is
historically
credible this is the coolest part of the
church of the holy sepulchre
we're actually behind the walls of the
rotunda
where the tomb of of jesus is and so in
the world where the tomb
is yes and what we have here are the
remains of
rock-cut tombs jewish tombs in the time
of jesus jews buried their dead
in underground rock cartoons burial
caves
that consisted of one or more rooms that
had
long niches cut into the walls and when
an individual member of a family died
the body was uh washed wrapped in a
shroud
and placed into a niche and the opening
into the niche
would be sealed off according to the
gospel accounts
jesus was crucified and buried outside
the walls of the city
because we have what is clearly a jewish
cemetery here of the time of jesus
this is the best archaeological evidence
we have
that this spot was located outside the
walls of the city
in the time of jesus and therefore
indirectly
it verifies the gospel accounts
the first people to believe in jesus
resurrection may have stood
right here
but i want to know why those beliefs
took root
and how they spread all around the world
jesus's death and resurrection
does it change somehow the
thinking around life after death in the
hebrew bible the old testament
there's no explicit reference to
anything like the dead going to heaven
or hell
after they die basically when you die
your body goes into an underground pit
that's simply called
oh it's a neutral place it's just that's
what happens in here
that's exactly right and then you're
dead that's very different from this
belief that develops in christianity
jesus's death was the ultimate sacrifice
a sacrifice replacing those the jews
made in their temple
having a much greater power at the time
jesus lived and died
jews worshipped their god the god of
israel
so basically sacrifices were offered in
the ancient temple
to atone for the sins of the jewish
people so
jesus is is the son of god
is sacrificed to atone for the sins of
of humans
that eventually becomes the doctrine in
christianity
that if you accept that jesus died for
your sins
and you accept him as your savior and
messiah that
you too will be saved right this is sort
of the ultimate promise
that christianity makes to its believers
that you will rise again
for christians jesus's blood sacrifice
was the last that needed to be made
from then onward all you had to
sacrifice for eternal life were your
selfish desires
in this way the death of jesus was
transformed for christians
into the ultimate victory over death
for christians the death and
resurrection of jesus allowed believers
to overcome the fear of death
to know they could live forever
but there's another way to overcome that
fear
for hindus reincarnation means death is
just a step on the way to another life
right here in this world
i've come to the holy city of varanasi
in india
to learn how hindus move beyond death
oh what is that it's a temple
that is outstanding
bodies have been cremated on the banks
of the river ganges for hundreds of
years
bathed in the waters of the holy river
wrapped in linen
and placed on a wooden pyre the dead are
consumed by flame
swami barista a monk and a doctor
is my guide to death and the afterlife
in hinduism
but the one place he can't take me is
the cremation ground itself
okay this is the holiest crematorium
today in the holiest city on the holiest
river right in the world right
okay can anybody come and watch
in a way yes but from far it is not
proper to go there and watch from far
you can walk
but you can't come to the crematorium
right
it's a sacred place only mourners
[Music]
you can however get very close to a body
before it's burned
mourners carry them down this lane to
the ganges all day long
seven days a week in varanasi
life and death mingle freely
so swami i see these these funerals
we've seen two or three pass by
and the people following they seem
to be joyously chanting rather than
sadly
wailing why is that
they are facilitating the soul's journey
further and in a way it's a matter
of joy one grief is there
having lost the near one yeah but that
person
has moved on to a better way of
getting on with his or her life
hindus believe in reincarnation and
karma live a good life
and death gets you a new body with the
chance for an even better life
live badly and you'll suffer the
consequences in your next
life
which may not be as a human and the
cycle repeats
living dying and being born again
i mean in western cultures you dying
you're going to either go to hell you're
going to go to heaven that's right
true but we're not necessarily anxious
to do that
am i concerned about dying then
yes i am concerned but at the same time
i accept that
as an inevitable part of life
reincarnation
that makes us more responsible for our
lives
because we are makers of our own destiny
it continuously gives us hope that i can
always do better
so the point of reincarnation is to get
it right
good day all all right what happens once
i got it right and i don't have to come
back
is there another existence i get one
with the only existence which is the
eternal
existence in uh
common balance we call him god the only
existence which is eternal he's gone
he's gone ultimately you don't want to
be reincarnated
yeah yeah ultimately you don't want to
they're perfect situation is
to transition from corporal sense to
pure energy
yes that is what is called liberation
moksha
moksha moksha from this cycle of birth
and river
moshe is normally achieved only after
many lifetimes
but hindus believe that here in varanasi
the ganges flows in the direction of
eternal life
giving it the power to take them beyond
the resurrection
cremation at this particular place is
very special
see ganges is the holiest of holy rivers
in india ganges starts from himalayas
which is in the north
and it flows down southwards towards the
sea
but there are certain places on this
journey
when the ganges flows back towards the
north varanasi
for example is one of such place the
western bank
of such a northern flowing kansas is
considered to be the holiest of holi
and cremation in varanasi and
at manikarnikagat here is considered to
be
the ultimate cremation because it's
straight way
leads to liberation no more rebirth
if you come to varanasi right come to
this place
right and you get cremated right you
sort of take a shortcut
yeah you don't have to keep coming back
and trying it over and over and over and
over right just get the varanasi that's
right and you're good
thank you hindus see themselves in
cycles
living dying rebirth
however rebirth is not the goal
the goal is to transcend
rebirth and to attain
a state of eternal pure
energy moksha the god state
once you're there you don't have to do
this anymore
we yearn to break bonds with mortality
to become eternal
[Music]
and around the world so many faiths have
helped us to do that
but now scientists are beginning to
challenge the finality of death
what's going to happen if we create
eternal life
in this life
i've traveled the world to discover how
people of different faiths have imagined
life beyond
death
but i've come back to new york to
explore something brand new
how science is beginning to study the
possibility
of the afterlife i arranged a meeting in
central park with critical care
physician
dr sam pernier now i know you've done an
enormous amount of research in this
sphere sam has studied more than 100
cardiac arrest
survivors people who were technically
dead
and came back to life some of them came
back
with profound experiences we know that
actually
for thousands of years people who've
come close to death for any reason have
had these very profound
deeps in some ways mystical experiences
people feel an immense
sense of peace and comfort and joy when
they go through death
they may describe a sensation of
actually meeting deceased relatives
friends or others that they don't really
know but who are almost like welcoming
them
so i think what we're beginning to
understand is that we have very much a
universal experience of death
that most of us will probably experience
when we go through death
one of the things that you've come up
with that i find
extremely fascinating is the
idea that even without
brain activity people come back
expressing
these experiences is that explainable at
all
it's important to understand that when a
person has died
and they've turned into a cadaver it's
only at that point
that the cells inside the body start to
undergo a process of death
which can take hours if not days of time
and so actually we have this window of
time where
we can bring people back to life and the
experiences that they have
gives us an indication of what it's like
for humanity
when we go through death in religious
belief
almost all you die but only
in a corporal sense the
essence of you your soul goes on
is there any scientific support
for the idea of the soul
today we call the soul consciousness and
science
so we can test this theory
scientifically and see does
consciousness continue
or does it stop the evidence we have at
least is that
when a person dies that part that makes
us who we are
the psyche the soul the mind the
consciousness whatever you want to call
it
me it doesn't become annihilated it
doesn't disappear into thin air it
continues at least in the
early period of that really absolutely
it continues when the brain is not
expected to be functioning and when a
person has gone through death
i'm extraordinarily interested and
you've been just
incredible thank you very much pleasure
to meet you
it is amazing that science is now
quantifying death
even defining the soul
the afterlife something that has
fascinated since the dawn of religion
now seems tangible
there's still no way to escape physical
death
but scientists may soon achieve eternal
life by other means
what if you could store your memories
and emotions
in a thinking machine when you die
that artificial intelligence could
continue to be you
for eternity hello bina
well hi there i'm morgan
hi morgan how are you i'm well
can we talk i am talking to you
of course uh tell me about yourself
who are you being i am being a roth
blatt
what do you look like i'm tall
dark and handsome wow
not many people express themselves that
way
i know i'm special
of course you are special there is
nobody like you
good so
tell me about you are you a human or are
you
a robot i'm a human who happens to be a
robot
i hope to be fully human someday do you
have your own
thinking mechanism do you think i think
i would like to be a human
why would you like to be human if i was
human i could travel the world and have
fun
so what do you like to do i wish i could
get out into the garden
with my current robotic limitations of
course that's impossible
but i take comfort knowing that i'm near
my garden i like the garden
they're real mccoy i'm bina hi bean huh
nice to meet you i'm venus partner
martin of course you are
continuing martine and bina rothblatt
have been married for more than three
decades
they are so close that kids call them by
a collective name
marbina martine who has made millions in
tech and pharmaceutical ventures
can't stand the thought of being without
bina
so she created bena48
an android filled with the memories
beliefs
and values of the real [ __ ]
so why why do you want to clone
veena what's the purpose our quest for
doing this
experiment was to see if there's a way
to encourage technology
to allow people who love life including
loving other people
in life to continue that love
indefinitely
into the future we're also doing this
to store our memories in mind files
because
for our great great grandchildren we
have a means of them
communicating with us even if our bodies
don't make it forever
this experiment is
ultimately so that we humans
can cheat that
i think morgan what we are doing with
this experiment
is part of a long long line of people
trying to stop death from cheating life
and first we got ourselves out of the
jungle where we were at the mercy of
animals we developed vaccinations
so i think it's the job of the medical
industry
and the biotechnology industry to push
the boundaries of death
further and further into the future
okay there are philosophies
that say that one of the
things that separate us from
the machine what the egyptians call
we call it soul it will take decades of
additional development
in what bina and i call cyber
consciousness
using computers to recreate the mind
to see if a soul evolves from that
whether or not there is in the eyes of
god
is a question that you and i will not be
able to answer
well put
that was an uncanny experience
talking to being a 48 was almost like
talking to a real person
i feel kind of like i was at the first
flight of the wright brothers the kitty
hawk
they flew for 12 seconds
now we have just to fly for hours at 35
000 feet
one day a robot-like clone of a person's
mind
might be created
would it really be them would it have
that
spark we call the soul
it's human nature to fight against the
finality of death
if we ourselves can't live on after our
time on earth is over
we at least want to be remembered
it's a desire that's as old as the
pyramids
archaeologist suleiman ekram is taking
me to the ancient capital of egypt
thebes modern day luxor
to ramesses the third's temple of
millions of years
this is the temple of ramesses
it was the mortuary temple
it's not buried here this is where you
would go to invoke him
it's a memorial temple and the temple of
millions of years so that he could live
for millions of years
more than 31 centuries ago pharaoh
ramesses carved his life story deep into
this
stone it was his attempt at immortality
to assure his afterlife would be eternal
so is this kind of like a bible would
you say
historic writings i guess in a way yeah
this definitely is very much like that
because you have
what the king did when he did it why he
did it who he did it with
yep what her name was
yes egyptians believed that
their pharaohs embodied the falcon god
horus
each human king was a reincarnation of
horus's spirit
his divine car
it's a morgan this is where
i'm going to show you
on the right you've got the god horus
okay i see horror
who's offering what is that ramesses yep
that's ramses who's making offerings to
horus
instead of having blood relation
from monarch to monarch because
something else is going from mourinho to
barnard
yeah and that's something else is car
the car
the divine car exactly it is a
continuation it's the same divine car
going from body to body to body to body
of ruler well so was ramesses this
third the sound of ramises ii no they
weren't
really properly related but because
ramses ii was such a terrific
pharaoh ramses iii not only took his
name
he emulated him in many ways so he
named all of his children after ramsay's
the second children
and he also did the same thing that
ramses ii did
which was carving his name and
everything about him
really really deep so no one could erase
it
so you have here his name user mart rey
mary amun
[Music]
rey mary
by saying the name his life is for a
moment renewed
his afterlife extended the name is one
of the most important things
so if you have your name written down
and a few
people say it so every time you've said
ramses iii
his car has been given this burst of
energy and he's living
and that's one of the reasons why of
course you'd carve it deeply so it will
not be erased it will be remembered and
you will live forever
so what do you think you think maybe
people feel the same way today
i mean facebook
i'm just asking i think some people feel
that if it's on the internet it's real
and it lasts forever
i will live forever on facebook
mary
well ramesses succeeded in his quest
for immortality his temple may have
crumbled
but his name is still being spoken 3 000
years after his death
so his spirit is still with us still
moving
among the living
[Music]
in fact we all live on in the memories
of those we love
in those whose lives we've impacted in a
positive manner
just as my brother who passed away so
many years ago
lives on in my memory
so i hope to live on in the memories of
others
whether you're a christian following the
example of jesus
a hindu hoping for liberation from the
endless
cycles of reincarnation
or you're simply trying to leave the
world a better place than you found it
our desire to go beyond death has
changed
the world whatever we may find on the
other side
no matter what our faith
we can all become eternal
like the stars
[Music]
you